we got j-rod this is j-rod oh yeah
we don't seen him in a grip yeah guys
crazy great way
oh yeah he's great great graze you died
and crazy dude j-rod dick or farting boy
oh I think farts is more enjoyable I
think because the fart is almost like a
joke it's like your butt telling like a
little like one-liner huh you know you
hear the one about them you know
and actually in some cultures they used
to try and decipher the sounds of body
gas farts oh yeah yeah they use the
culture meant something you know a
culture is human culture man all of them
dude probably eighty [ __ ] percent one
huh pick one culture human okay dude I'm
saying is was it the Asians was it the
black hole dude I'm Hispanic but we're
one for one culture man human culture
dude okay you know I got somebody trying
to decipher a fart sound
I thought the Koreans did it yeah I
would be shocked you're seeing a scat
video huh you ever seen scab Bay know
what like somebody telling a cat to get
away real fast yeah kind of look it up
alone
really yeah smoke a cigarette watch that
video my mom used to always see it oh
yeah it's also a jazz TIMSS cats cats
cats cats get it get it yeah look it up
um I'm a dick joke guy oh yeah I like
dicks better in a weird non home away I
think it takes it's way funnier you pick
the wrong one
dee what do you think you dude I think
again it goes extreme and like like
dick jokes about fr jokes diarrhea jokes
about dick jokes you know I mean I think
going on some all day really nothing fun
in a good big dick joke well digs have
always been a little bit more popular I
think you know because dicks is um
remember these have those shirts big
Johnson shirts and it was all about dick
you know yeah I think that's the number
of those big Johnson know what your
mother slim-jim commercials was about
dicks too
why that's about a snack dick but you
remember big Johnson shirts you talking
about big Johnson the truck took my big
Johnson dog big Johnson big that [ __ ]
big Johnson are you talking that's the
porno star it's gonna call big Johnson
right there it says let's not confuse a
wall Oh big Johnson brah
there you go Johnson uh bungee jumpin
it's his wiener oh I do remember these
shake Johnson great [ __ ] reference
yeah dad
so dicks had their own shirt they never
really had like a um a fart shirt yeah
like loud Randle or something you know
on a turn I never had like a shirt for
like body gas you know big Johnson got
that's such a [ __ ] remember back put
out the fire with big Johnson hoses and
it would be seeing his own dick into a
fire he's like the couch Patch dolls but
for [ __ ] remember that there's no
Garbage Pail Kids
oh yeah yeah big dick johnson god that's
right that's such an old-school
reference dude so yeah I think that's
the thing that you should know about
having a big dick and I did my research
cuz I was like what am I gonna do with
this thing
you so here it is back in the day in the
Greek culture you know if you had a big
dick you're made fun of it's a bad move
so we know all the statues in Italy all
the great men have these tiny dicks
that's not true dude you don't think now
if you had a big dick that everyone made
fun of you I'm sure well the big dick
looks dumb bro you know I'm saying you
run it you know people are it's more
about you know just one guy's a small
dick say really that's what I heard dude
I'll [ __ ] tie my dick around your neck
right now
I'll tie it all the way around your neck
and won't even feel it stretch bungy
jump rope it's good I rolled over one
night in bed my penis fell out of bed
and broke the back of a full-grown cat
here Lestat oh that's how that cat why
god no I don't know man I think but yeah
a big dick looks dumb as you get older
you're just like this old guy carrying
around this dick and his back is all
hurt yeah I feel bad for those guys yeah
sometimes I'll mmm a porno pop up and
this dude will have just a monster dick
I'm like what's he gonna do when he gets
older dude yeah that thing's too big
well then you got to get a little like a
lunch kit and bring it you got to carry
it in front of your body limbs got to
get a crutch yeah just hold it up but it
yeah are one of those wheeling crutches
like they got never but he's a little
bit afraid to walk their own leg around
those guys are another level man who are
they porno stars dude you never seen
like the big dick porno stars I don't
know their names would be so miserable
if I'd [ __ ] twice I don't know their
names disease Oh Riko strong he's my
favorite Wesley Pipes he's good sleep I
mean it's all the [ __ ] he's always
thought [ __ ] oh wow talk [ __ ] to the
girl Jordan yeah damn yeah he's like
Kanye West of porn oh yeah yeah damn I
don't know the guys yeah I just other
dudes do you think if I if we picked
five more stars and put their dicks in a
lineup you could pick them no I bet
Derek how many would you get out of five
though one out of five oh we get none
out of five and Derek how many we got a
four out of five you know you dicks yeah
now here's it can you girl do the same I
don't know if she's watching the porn
like watch porno with you girl yeah we
do oh but not like it's not like my
office not as much you know that all the
time do y'all watch it like in a popcorn
and stuff like that is it that kind of
thing where you do it at night I can
watch it on the do you watch it you
watching like scheduled viewing or is it
like you don't have like meals around
like watching Josh
yeah they would kind of savage me I
don't know what about cat cants actually
see more wieners probably hopefully the
most of us so I don't I like to watch
porn alone I'm not that fun of watching
porn with other people yeah do you like
girl-on-girl yes
oh that does nothing for me I made it I
feel like I'm like watching girl-on-girl
only when the girls are like drop-dead
gorgeous yes just looking at another one
a beautiful woman is just so much more
appealing to me okay yeah that'll buy
you to be so you like like you don't
like like the butch lesbians hmm if
she's gorgeous
venture well then she ain't butch if
she's gorgeous cat well she got like
Theo she ain't go home or bowling then
but you know yeah well well there you go
you know yeah and I'm gonna see the
submission man what an amazing
submission video that guy's a legend too
sometime yeah straight up legend 75% of
people went with dicks on that
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching